évidemment une super bonne nouvelle pour
nous on a très hâte que ça soit mis en
place rapidement mais encore
insuffisante pour plusieurs résidents
nous ce qu'on demande pas juste des
mesures ponctuelles autour des écoles
mais c'est aussi carrément une vision
d'ensemble car les intersections sont
achalandées et les automobilistes au
comportement problématique nombreux on
peut pas passer sur les passages piétons
tous
les Sherbrooke jusqu'à tout récemment
Hugues l'évêque était le brigadier mais
à midi en 90 minutes j'ai compté 62
infractions mais c'est pas c'est même
pas les excès de vitesse d'un contexte
actuel les enfants sont en sécurité moi
je suis pas en sécurité d'autant plus
qu'ils se font rares ces brigadiers
c'est toujours une bataille obtenir un
brigadien un endroit qu'on juge
dangereux ça demande une démarche ça
demande de la mobilisation une
mobilisation citoyenne qui réclame
Mousty des actions de la part du
gouvernement provincial ici Jacques
Audric Charbonneau Radio-Canada MONT